ما الذي تشكله انقر المعتز بالله من اهميه
في كل انتخابات شهدتها تركيا وفي هذه
الانتخابات على وجه التحديد بالنظر ايضا
الى توجهات الناخبين هناك وما يتحكم فيها
الاهميه التي تشكلها انقره هي ليس من
ناحيه العدد فعدد السكان سكان انقره
هو اقل من مدينه اسطنبول وايضا عدد النواب
الذين سترسلهم الى البرلمان هو اقل من عدد
النواب الذين سترسلهم اسطنبول لكن اهميتها
هي في انها العاصمه السياسيه لتركيا
وبالتالي من يفوز يفوز بهذه العاصمه هو
ايضا يحقق نصر معنويا ولذلك هناك اهتمام
كبير من قبل التحالفات كلها بالعاصمه نحن
نتحدث عن
ربما ثاني مدينه من حيث عدد النواب الذين
ترسلهم المدن الى البرلمان انقر سترسل 36
نائبا الى البرلمان بعد اسطنبول الذي
سترسل ثمانيه وتسعين نائبا وايضا هناك
ربما تنافس شديد فيما يتعلق
بالانتخابات الرئاسه خصوصا وان هناك في
بعض المناطق او بعض المدن الصغيره داخل
انقره تعتبر من الاعلى كثافه سكانيا
سكانيا في عموم تركيا نحن نتحدث عن مدينه
شنقايه داخل العاصمه انقره هناك اكثر من
مليون و200 الف هذه الاعداد هي اعداد
كبيره والمنافسه فيها لذلك هي تكون مهمه
جدا لحسم نتائج التصويت وان كان هناك ربما
المنافسه الاعلى هي في اسطنبول ولذلك
راينا ان الرئيس التركي
رئيس
تحالف الشعب المعارض ايضا او الاهتماما
لمدينه اسطنبول الى انقره رمزيتها في انها
العاصمه السياسيه لتركيا وهي المدينه التي
انساها انشاها مؤسسه الجمهوريه مصطفى كمال
اتاتورك بالنسبه لسكانها هناك ايضا قيمه
في ذلك وبالتالي كل هذا هو ضمن يضعه
الناخب في في عقله وهو يتوجه للتصويت ما
شاهدناه خلال الايام الماضيه والناس الذين
استطلعنا ارائهم كان هناك الكثير من ربما
التفكير في كيف سيكون هذا الصوت خصوصا وان
هناك كما تحدثنا سابقا في نشاط سابقه ان
هناك ايضا ازمه اقتصاديه ولكن في المقابل
هناك انجازات قامت بها تركيا خلال السنوات
الماضيه العقدين الماضيينو وكل هذا هو في
عقل النخب وهو يتوجه الى صندوق الاقتراع